place à la page spécialité de ce journal
on retrouve tout de suite bérénice du
fayé en direct d'orléans bon sens mais
ray nice alors actuellement leurs
caisses des jeunes du centre est en
tournée dans toute la région après tours
et châteauroux lors qu'elle sera investi
la cathédrale d'orléans pour un concert
ce soir et les jeunes musiciens ont
répété tout l'après midi
est ce qu'ils sont prêts ben oui
évidemment olivier ils sont prêts et
j'ai envie de dire ils n'attendent que
ça jouer devant un vrai public ce soir
la cathédrale d'orléans sera
probablement plein à craquer pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que c'est un
orchestre de qualité
et puis parce que c'est un orchestre qui
est née il y à orléans en 1985 grâce à
un monsieur qui est très connu ici à
orléans un certain henri claude joubert
alors on les a filmés effectivement
répétition cet après midi petit extrait
reportages et on se retrouve juste après
avec mon invité leurs instruments sous
le bras les jeunes pousses de leur
caisse se sont d'abord installés dans la
sacristie la cathédrale un peu stressé
mais heureux d'être là je fais du vélo
qui je suis
cinq ans et leur cas c'est ce que je
préfère parce qu'on est avec deux
musiciens partagent notre passion et les
stages comme ça c'est encore plus
enrichissant on est souvent
en collectivité avec d'autres musiciens
et et c'est vraiment ce qui me passionne
on partage la passion et et ses ventes
formidable orchestre des jeunes cessant
de musiciens le plus jeune a 14 ans le
plus âgé la trentaine passée par le
conservatoire ils viennent de toute la
france pour apprendre et se former
certains sont là pour en faire leur
métier d'autres noms travaillent
énormément
c'est maintenant fait huit heures et
demi de la tête par jour
c'est intense parce que là on travaille
beaucoup on étouffe la journée à
répétition et
c'est passé
sport ce soir elles interpréteront
strauss mozart debussy et ginastera un
programme de grands devant un vrai
public les musiciens qui sont derrière
la cdc potentiellement les musiciens qui
vont être dans les orchestres français
et étrangers de demain et d'après demain
certains sont très très jeune et ils
sont encadrés là en plus cette année
avec des musiciens déjà professionnels
dont ils connaissent ce milieu et qui
leur font profiter toute leur expérience
pour justement au service de la
formation du musicien de métier de
musicien en question
le concert dans la cathédrale dans l'est
on est prévue ce soir à 20h30 demain ils
prendront la direction de tours puis
celle de richelieu une aventure humaine
à ne pas rater
bonsoir mahut 6 gorce dame alors c'est
vous qui dirigez tous ces jeunes talents
en point c'est essentiel pour tous ces
jeunes de passer par un orchestre
symphonique lancaster symphonique est
très important pour les coûte parce que
en encaisseront peut dire ça une société
une petite société à la il faut donner
quelque chose et en même temps il faut
écouter et ça c'est un entraînement
c'est vraiment ça se passe par étapes et
voilà tant logiciels de notre eau qu est
ce qui fait maintenant son 30e
anniversaire
il ya une bonne ambiance il un bonne
structure et je suis sûr que tout le
monde tous les stagiaires profite bien
de notre stage
alors on vous a vu tout à l'heure en
vous a vu en répétition vous êtes à la
fois très proche et en même temps vous
ne lâchez sur rien vous avez la même
exigence qu avec des musiciens confirmés
absolument absolument il faut et il n'y
a pas de différence moi je trouve
contrairement en fait vraiment un
travail
e
professionnel avec parce que ça dépend
de la de la concentration se relâcher et
ont même tout de suite attaqué et viser
le problème c'est pas facile mais avec
lui ça marche très bien dans ce qu'il ya
une très bonne volonté et en même temps
il ya eu beaucoup d'humour vous
dialoguez avec que vous vous riez pas ce
que vous travaillez beaucoup de travail
huit heures par jour mais on sent qu'il
ya une ambiance vraiment quelque chose
d'amical entre vous ça c'est important
surtout parce que la musique
on a parlé de ça il faut donner quelque
chose c'est une question de confiance
la confiance est est ce que dans cet
orchestre ya des jeunes pépites vous ai
dit à la latière celui là il sera
forcément dans un orchestre reconnu
notre nous sommes maintenant dans le
10ème jour je pense ça veut dire la
confiance ça c'était quelque chose qui
s'est construite et voilà et nous avons
très très bonne équipe autour de l'
orchestre autour de moi en eau de lépine
deal encore les qui me vraiment qui me
soutiennent qu'ils donnent beaucoup d
idées qui aussi qui font attention que
nous envisageons ensemble toujours le
même but des cancers par exemple de
concert ce soir à l'ordinaire petite
question vous vous êtes un fan de
musique vous êtes aussi l'assistant du
directeur musical de l'opéra de paris
très court pourquoi la musique c'est
toute votre vie
marius parce que dans musique
ça c'est le contact les musiques c'est
la musique ça veut dire comme j'ai dis
donnez écouter se parlent et échangent
et voilà comme respiration c'est la vie
merci beaucoup je souhaite un très très
bon concert et puis je rappelle ce soir
à la cathédrale d'orléans 20h30 et puis
c'est gratuit bérénice on y sera et
merci pour cette parenthèse musicale